you willing to bleed out of your [__]
eyes for your dream answer is you're not
because you're full of [__] do you know
many people like I'm gonna be the next
breakout rapper and they never work on
their craft they don't write they don't
go to the studio they're not willing to
do what Prince did Prince was a janitor
in return for being in studio time do
you know any of my friends back at the
Ida were like oh but I own the money for
studio time so go [__] work I did
ain't [__] without execution let me give
a good example of this for everybody
wake up in the morning and go garage
sailing and flea marketing every Friday
Saturday and Sunday buy random [__] and
then sell it on eBay you can make 500
bucks a week just learning video games
newspaper magazines magazines is the
best Arbitrage you can go to any [__]
garage sale and buy a bucket of
magazines for a dollar and then sell
them for three bucks a piece on eBay all
day but are you willing to bleed out of
your [__] eyes for your dream answer
is you're not because you're full of
[__]